congratulations I just wanted to know
what has this partnership between you
guys meant to you what does it meant and
how do you plan on you know celebrating
once you're together well I don't for me
it just like I honest to god I said this
a thousand times I know that we haven't
spent a whole lot of time together like
in in the flesh but like I really do
feel like we're friends and that I feel
like makes the biggest difference in
things like this um I feel like we're
like I've made a friend in Blake and
hopefully he feels like he's made a
friend in me and I think that would be
the most important thing to move from
you know I think our partnership between
between Todd's energy and my lack of
energy together we make one normal human
being perfect combination news and I
can't honestly I can't wait to be in the
same room with Todd and hang out with
him and I want to perform with him
onstage like I want to get past whatever
you know whatever we got to do here to
get past this this this pandemic and get
back to normal life and and and get on
stage with this guy because he's he
truly is a rush to be around and and I
want to I want to sing with this guy
that's what I'm looking forward to I
know we did it on the show and we did it
this way but you know we got to do it
the right way don't you think Todd oh
yeah oh man look the minute the minute
they tell us we can number I'm ready to
go I got a car gassed up right now just
describe for me what it was like the
final minute of the show leading up to
the announcement and then what it was
like when you heard your name called as
the winner you know man the final minute
of the show I think he if you make the
voice finale that's a win and so like I
was less nervous tonight then I was
before but my kids were freaking out so
I felt like I went into like dad mode
where I was like y'all just chill out
it's fine it's all good it's all good
you know
so it was really hard to even focus on
being nervous which was good for me I
guess but then immediately when my name
was called oh no just the whole room
erupted and I don't remember a lot I've
blacked out for a second so I don't know
everything went everything's great
Blake if I could just ask you real quick
what do you think put Todd over the top
against a very talented group of
finalists well I think Todd is every bit
as talented as the other four that were
in the finale I think the thing that may
have put him over the top is his
relatability I mean this guy is
literally someone that we all feel like
lives down the street from us or at
least we hope and and he's somebody that
I think everybody hopes they can meet
one day you know and you can't say that
about everybody that you see on
television or hear on the radio but when
you then you really start to buy into
just to the person that you're seeing on
TV plus they happen to be you know have
the world-class talent that that todd
has I mean it was just it was just an
unstoppable combination and and I'd like
to add one that I think we started
seeing early early on you know because
you know behind the scenes and even you
know in front of the camera there was a
lot of talk about Todd there was always
constant talk about Todd and people just
knew there was something special about
the guy so I gotta say I'm not I'm not
surprised to be sitting here having this
this press conference with as with him
as the winner of the boys because
there's just something about him I just
felt like in the blind auditions that I
had an ace in the hole the second he
chose me as his coach given the new
format of remote shows this season we
haven't really seen anything like it
before
I want to know what the biggest
adjustment you both had to make this
season was obviously Blake it doesn't
matter what the format is it doesn't
matter if it's zoom FaceTime you're
still the winner so I guess it didn't
have much of a role on your success well
you know Todd this is the only way to
actually that's not true todd todd has
had to has gotten to experience you know
both sides of this he he was at the show
he was at the studio he had the audience
he got to feel what it's like to be on
the voice that way and then he had to
had to feel what it's like to do it this
way and of course as as performers we
always want to be in front of a live
audience and I think but I think it
shows the strength of all of these
artists actually to to make a connection
this way because this is hard it's even
hard to to you know make comments and
you know it's it's just it's just a you
have to kind of relearn how to exist in
live television when you're doing it
from your house yeah I don't know talk
talk probably has a lot of thoughts on
it too but it's it's been crazy yeah I
mean I would say first of all like I
think all 20 of us in the top 20 were
like of course like disappointed that we
weren't going to get this experience
that we had sort of really like kind of
built our lives around for a little
while you know but for me like first of
all over time you just get accustomed to
it that's how life works you adjust you
know and so we did that but then
whenever whenever we did love me and I
saw that back I'm like this is why I'm
at home for this this is why you know
and so I've told everybody when they
asked the pros and cons like there's I
think it's even though it got a little
hectic and stressful sometimes it's kind
of neat that we got to learn how to use
this equipment and and even where to put
the lights and things like that so the
pro is it's really that my family is
here with me and the con is that my
family is here with me what's the first
thing besides obviously an app but
what's the first thing that you really
have to do because we now live in the
world of the unknown so we need you out
there but there's different ways to for
you to get out there right well you know
the the first thing I'm going to have to
figure out and I'm not sure how I'm
going to figure it out because the world
is shut down is my wife without my
permission
my kids we would go to Disney World if I
won so everybody's like dad said if
we're going DS where all my dad did not
say that mom mama said you know but you
know what I really want to do and I
don't really know I this is all brand
new to me and but I think that's good
though I think if I come into it
understanding that I don't really have a
great understanding then I can find
people and I have even in these weeks
that I've been on the voice Blake
Shelton is one of them but then other
people I can find people that are part
of this industry that are connected but
also gifted and talented and I can sort
of glean from them you know like what
you know that was the number one thing
when I think I even said either in my
battle or knockout like I need you guys
to help me about genre and now that I'm
here at the end I feel way more
confident about which direction you know
to go in so I'm just gonna continue to
like glean from them and learn from them
and I've got you know I've got several
songs that I've worked on and the the
song that that song man did Ryan
innocent song wind up that song I hope
to find a way to I don't really know how
to get it outside of iTunes but we'll
figure it out but just to go for it
that's my plan man I was like I'm
putting all the chips on the table very
cool and for Blake is this the beginning
of your rivalry with Nick Jonas or
because your vibe feels like the same
vibe with the what you had with you and
Adam you know the the the difference
with with with Nick and Adam is you know
Adam was here for the for the first
season so I built a strong eight you
know what was a 17 16 season's worth of
a grudge against Adam to where you know
there was nothing it became a part of my
existence to beat him now with with Nick
you know I don't want to feel like I'm
just picking on on a kid you know coming
in coming into the show and and and and
sadly for Nick you know too
to have Todd Tillman you know agreed to
let me be his coach and then come in and
and it's like you ever seen that show
that movie over the top
absolutely yeah uh you know Sylvester
Stallone he's already strong but then he
has that move where he does that weird
thing and then he that's what taught so
that's why it's hard was like coming off
my chambers that extra loop on there and
I slammed him down
[Laughter]